Best.
Teamup.
Ever.
Heroes vs Aliens, the 4 Night Crossover Event
starts with Supergirl Monday November 28th.
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so we finally
got some 4 night crossover footage, so I'm
going to do a breakdown, explain some of what's
happening why it's happening and some of the
mechanics behind it, so here we go.
I'm Stephen Amell, I'm grant Gustin
Hey Everyone, I'm Caity Lotz. I'm Brandon Routh.
the crossover scenes, we're all there. I got to play with everyone.
on the arrow team, we bring back Sara I think
Supergirl anymore girl power like I'm into
it though definitely Supergirl distributed
more than when she meets Supergirl she's like
a little intimidated she's so used to being
like the chick that has everything under control
and now all of a sudden there's like this
alien I can levitate and she's like okay I
respect you I see you you cannot disregard
all character directionally came to Oliver
to cut around I'm usually with the cold shoulder
or just for just as is all called saying hello
to work as much with the flash as I like to.
Ray good friends team flash wants Ray Palmer
moment like were all there, though.
So there was a big promo shoot
It's a little tongue-in-cheek like you see
all of her reading Robinson Crusoe will Barry
and Kara play video games Robinson Crusoe
if you haven't read it is a story about a
man who gets marooned on an island and then
you see Caity Lotz reading the invasion comic
book like he's actually reading the story
is going to be happening during the crossover
is having a little bit of fun in there were
actual pictures from the episode that he is
a whole bunch more stuff you can't really
pick out which episode they fallen but you
can kind of guess based on the characters
that appear you see Sarah Laurel here that
might be during the arrow episode we had the
overarching story of the dominators invasion
that will stretch over each episode and then
within each episode will have a very flash
centric story.
You have a very arrow centric story that's
the hundredth episode of arrow two so that
be a lot of deep cuts happening during that.
But then they'll resolve that on legends of
tomorrow is because that the last night.
So even though just like a really quick trailer
there just letting you know, this is all starting
November 28 that's a Monday Supergirl is only
going to lightly address it because it's in
a different universe theory goes and gets
her brings her to the flash so November 29
that flash episode is really like the beginning
of the huge dominators invasion storyline
is the Supergirl episodes only going to lightly
address that but obviously I'll be doing videos
for each of those four normally haven't been
doing Supergirl episodes but all totally do
a Supergirl video as part of the for my crossover.
So even though you have this big invasion
each of the episodes will have like its own
special flash centric story that will deal
mostly with those characters but obviously
like part of the fun of this is introducing
Supergirl to everyone because no one is better
besides Barry yet so you have that then you
have all the extra arrow 100 episode Easter
egg stuff happening because this is going
to be a big love letter to the fans.
They did everything they could to include
every big character that has ever been featured
on the show that's dextrose that's Walter
that's Oliver's father so there's gonna be
so much stuff happening and that episode in
particular make sure if you're not able to
watch it that night that you set your DVR
just because it's going to be a really big
deal for the other big thing is everybody's
comic book costumes, especially citizens deals
it shows up in this promo art here this is
probably from the fourth night of the crossover
so because of that that costume teaser for
killer Frost and vibe we might not see those
in this episode but I would be too surprised
they just might be misleading us with some
of the way these pictures look so let me know
in the comments do you think that everybody's
going to get their comic book costume in the
for my crossover and what you think the big
twist is going to be because they did say
that my control is and has something to do
with it like you see flash and arrow here
looking like they're getting ready to fight
Diggle is obviously some trick that the dominators
pull so there's really like so much going
on that we don't know they'll probably release
a couple more trailers before the episode
drops just because it's a couple weeks away
but they are going to sink the episodes up
before that happens of the they happened in
the right order, right now the flash is an
episode behind because the US election that
happened this week so don't worry everything
will happen in the right order will just post
updates on the schedule as we learn more about
that in the DC giveaway still going on right
now.
I mean for my crossover trailer to deal courses
can be giveaway going on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video will announce
the winner when I post my legends of tomorrow
video which will be my next video to post
that will be on Friday morning.
If you haven't seen it Miami Vice reverse
flash Legion of doom.
Probably one of the best episodes they've
had so far, so be sure to watch it while you
wait for that to post you can click here for
my arrow Prometheus Dolph Lundgren video and
you can click here to learn all about Young
Justice Season Three.
Thank you so much for watching everybody let's
high five and I'll see you guys tonight